N
.
HE .CA A PERPS   HIS
VIID HE THINGBA HIM UP.
OF COURSE, THAT WANOGHT THINGNG.
SOURCES ODREJECTED WHA W IS A
AL JOE BIDE
PRESENTT
COFOUNDER OF LINCO COINS ME NOW
FO DIVE INTO SOME OF
TH L CHALLE, MITCHELLND
McCARTHYND D
I EXTRE THE REST
HISE BUT HOW LO
IT?>>ARE DRE
THEY SHOULDN'T BE ABLE TO DO IT
WAS ANNT TOULD H
INTING THENAIL, LAST NAILOFFIN R
WHICH IS AON F  U CES
2 OF THEUTION IF STATES
UBSTANFI IN THEIRTAPRESIDENTIAL
CONCLUSIVE UPON AND ALL STATESRA
GEORGIA,MI
ARIZ
CAN GOHT ONARCHIVES.G'E THE CER
GOVERNORS?
>> DUCEYNDKEMP,
THIS IS OVER. HAS BN A LONGIT'S
LONG TIME AND IT'S CRAZYHATHIS
>> CRUZS SUPREME COURT TAKE
LAWSUIT I GEORGIAHI
PA THEEPUBLINNSYLVAN.
HE ON SO I'M HOPEFUL THECO STEP
ACCORDING TO T ON,
S  CRYRESPECT THE RULE OFAW WEOE
NTARYLLS O
INST YOU MAY SEE
ONHER DES SAYS ANDVEREDGES THAT
RES IN
PEANIA
BEYONSYLVANIA ICAN SORY OBVIOUS
OPPOSITE APPHLING
PHAD   OF THECLEA
WON THE .
DO YOUHIS CHATHE SUPREME C NOT .
THERMENT BECAUSET ARGUE EMERGEN.
THERAL CAS THE
TO ACCEPTSO CASE CAMEM STATENSYA
ISSUE WAS WHETHER OR NOT THE
CHAPTER LAWHASED 2019YOU KNOW, E
REPUICHESL VI PENNSYLUP
S'TGO
IN THIS PIT THEY 'T HAV THIS
LAWSUIT BROUGHTTOO
IFHIS  C HEELRE ONLYAKE
ALDECIDE,ON TO DECIDE WHATTAS.
EY T S SO
PESY
YOU PR  THE PE
HAS THEORDRE.
THERE IS JUST FED
IN THIS CASE IS NO FOR THE INJUF
ER A  IFE SOME KIND OF AN,WATO
ES, INCLUDIN ,
HEARCHIV U.S.HA OVERTURNINCERTIN
AND AN ORDER A NEW
ELECTION IS HELD ANE.
>> ISTE O
THE AOHIMATTER,
HE IG THE SUPREME COURT
TO T LAWSUIT TOOVERTHCTION RESU
INCLUDG >> MT THING
YET.THE SUPREME ICTESTES A USUAI
THE NOTION THAT SUPREURT IS GOIE
AND THRE TO D
THAT AT IN TIME.
THATSU FOR  T THEM TO FILE A
LA
COURT HAS THEN TO JUST
DENY BSE T
WANT TO HHE BRI SOMEWHERE E LIEE
IT.
FOR EXAMPLE, THEY ABALLOT DUMPS
ND
ALI
CHANCE O SOMETHING LIKE THAT
THAT ALL OF THES THESE
VOTES WOULDAVE EN
DEMOCRATIC.
THEY ARE PRENLICANS ARE
EQUALLY MIXED IN MAIL-IN , TI I
THAT, ID O NOTIFFERENT FROM
PHILADPHIA.
>> RIGHT.
>> I MEAN, IT'S
I MEAN, WE AKNOW.
WE HAVE WATCHED ECT  WE HAVE T E
IN AND A AN SO WE CAN'T CL THIS
ANOMALOUS THAT SOMEESOME POINTSC
UN IS -- FOR AOF THE SUPRERT BA
TH IN THE SUPRE COURT
UNITED STATES IS US.THINALLEGAT
UM NOT PUTN F THEIRAINTS IN L D.
'SURDC LO ORBE SUPREME COURT BA
>> LASTLY, STATE M VOTES
AND  JOE BIDEN'S WIN
OFFICIAL FOR THE0t ISWAYO N WANS
A BTLE ON THE HOUSE FLOOR
SI, DOES CHEF
THE ABILITY TO MAKEURT
DOESN'T HAPPEN?
DON'T KNOWHEIAMENT RULES BUT THT
MENTIED AT THE
NN OURHERE.
>> SE THOSE EOR STATESILE THEIR
CERTIFICY TODAY AREDENOT SAY THE
ARE ELECTORS HAVE BEEN
TSYLVANIA AND
WISCONSIN, THEY ELLTHAT.
HE GET- BIDENETOBODY
ABO ANDCAN MAKE ALL OF THE NOIS.
'SASSMENT.
ERNG SEGOF THE AME
WANTS TO B SOMLDRU BIGGEST FECLO
MAIL-INP
WH
HE LIE TT HE
HEECTI